so the only thing that can top that
Jessie maybe my monologue I would agree
let's do it so can you repeat the
question sir can you repeat the question
sir that went a little fast for me could
you repeat that ma'am and you repeat the
last part of that question yeah can you
repeat the question the impact pardon
can you read the last question the last
question was certainly got an accurate
again can you repeat the question and
where are you reading from on that I'm
reading from my question then could you
repeat it this is very very painful
those aren't my words but david axelrod
a Democrat tweeting about the hearing
yep as much as they'd hoped for a 12
alarm fire all the Dems got was a damped
sparkler they wanted the Empire Strikes
Back but got a rerun of Matlock they
wanted a Super Bowl instead they got a
test pattern so was it a disaster for
the Democrats I think this has been a
disaster for the Democrats and I think
it's been a disaster for the reputation
of Robert Muller he has seemed very
uncertain with his brief he doesn't know
seemed to know what things that are in
the report but don't just take it from
him I had to watch the thing to no
choice it was on at the gym and it was
either that or Real Housewives if you
did a shot every time Muller said could
you repeat the question you'd be dead
but that's not molars fault it's the
Dems still intent on reliving the past
hoping the ending changes but it can't
there like a guy who got dumped and
thinks playing their song over and over
might rekindle the romance the
conclusion same as before
Moeller says Trump's not guilty but the
Dems want him to go beyond that and say
okay Trump may not be guilty but that
doesn't mean he's innocent that his
Trump wasn't exonerated but exoneration
declaring someone innocent is impossible
watch this painful exchange mr. Martin
does the Attorney General have the power
or authority to exonerate when I'm
putting up here as the United States
Code this is where the Attorney General
gets his power and the Constitution and
the annotated ver
cases of these which we've searched we
even went to your law school because I
went to Case Western but I thought maybe
your law school teaches it differently
and we got the criminal law textbook
from your law school mr. Muller nowhere
in these because we had them scanned is
there a process or description on
exonerate there's no office of
exoneration to turn in general's office
there's no certificate at the bottom of
his desk mr. Miller would you agree with
me that the Attorney General does not
have the power to exonerate I'm gonna
pass on that why this is the headline on
all of the news channels while you were
testifying today molar Trump was not
exonerated now mr. Muller what you know
is that this can't say Muller exonerated
Trump because you don't have the power
or authority exonerated Trump that did
not go well and so a 400-page lump
crafted by unhappy agenda-driven
staffers collapses like a bad souffle as
Trump continues to unleash an economy
that lifts all boats his adversary sits
stranded arms flailing going nowhere
stuck in the past as the future starts
looking like 2016 all over again the
Democrats wanted so badly from Muller to
give his report new life instead he took
it out to the woods shot it